donné naissance à un garçon
une semaine avant les élections
du 20 septembre.................
♪ ♪ ♪
- Je suis fébrile!
♪ ♪ ♪oioioioioioioioioioioioiois
que je grimpe cette colline,
qus s s s s rentrer
dans cet immeuble.
♪ ♪ ♪
députée à Ottawa. Premier pas
dans un nouvel uni
qu'elle a hâte d'apprivoiser.
NATHALIE SINCLAIR-DESGAGNÉ, dép.
- Je porte, avec moi,
120 000 personnequququququement,
qui m'accompagnent dans
ce nouveau mandat, donc
de la responsabilité en montant
cette colline qui... qui est
vraiment une colline!
(applaudissements)
- Bien le bonjour!
- Diplômée de l'Université
McGill et d'Oxford, l'économiste
participe ààààààààààààààààààààà.
- On a une opportunité unique
d'inclure tous les enjeuxla rel.
Je suis économiste,
donc évidemment...
tout ce qui a trseseseseseseses.
je peux y contribuer.
- La députée parle
couramment espagnol,
la langue de sa mère péruvienne,
une avocate émérite en
immigration igigigigigigigigigit
sexistes. C'est un garçon quie ,
il dit : "Qui sache coudre
et qui sache sache cuisiner."
pour... elle avait changé
les mots pour "qui sache
écrire", parce que ça rimait,
"qui sache écrire et
Merci beaucoup de
votr
- Nathalie Sinclair-Desgagné
est devenue maman et députée
Une semaine après
mememememememement, elle était
déjà de retour au travail.
comme nouvelle élue.
comme un sacrifice?iriririririr.
Je suis fière de représenter
une tranche de la popula q q q t
les deux à la fois. Puis,jejejes
être entre bonnes mains.
ÉMILE GRENIER-ROBILLARD
conjoint de Nathalie
une année avec mon petit garçon
et d'aider Nathalie à
la meilleure députée possible,
pour une cause qui me tient
l'indépendance du Québec;
onrérérérérérérérés
en militant pour ça.
♪ ♪ ♪
une famille très politisée quir.
À comsgsgsgsgsgsgsgsgsgsgsgsgsg.
- Il a enseigné,
d'ailleurs, à Lucien Bouchard
et je crois qu'il a enseigné
Mon grand-père a été
candidat aux éle
du Parti québécois en 1973,
donc au moment où il avait
à Chicoutimi; ça a été r r r r .
Il a ensuite été candidat
dans Dubuc, donc justeôôôôôôôôô.
- Unarararararararararararararat
rencontrés au doctorat à Yal
- Demain, caucus
toute la journée.suit les trace.
Après une maîtr
elle travaille chez
PriceWaterhouseCooper à Londres,
- Le choc de rentrer à Montréal
ettetetetetetetetetetenant,
le français n'était plus
une exigence dans plusieursesess
qui parlaient à peine français.r
qu'à Montréal, nos dossiers...
il y avaits s s s s s s s s s s.
Toutes les décisions
étaient prises à Toronto,
ne pas intervenir. Pour moi,
ça a été un choc
j'arrivais de gros projets,
avec de gros dossiers et...
je me retrouvais à Montréal,
mais comme j'étais à Montréal,
ma voix n'était plus............
(sonnerie de téléphone)
cabinet-conseil demeure
captivant pour la jeune
économiste, jusqu'à la pandémie.
alors que des gens souffrent
à côté... ça me... j'étais
complètement déconnectée.
suis dit : coudonc, il faut
que je...........
(cloches)
le sentiment nationaliste n'aa ,
le besoin d'aider son prochain.
- Quandédédédédédédédédédédédéde
organisme à but non l
parce que ma mère m'avait
beaucoup parlé des enfants
étant péruvienne.J'J'J'J'J'J'J't
pendant toute mon adolesu,u,u,u,
en leur envoyant des
fournitures scolaires.
♪ ♪ ♪
Disons que ça a quand même
àààààààààààà ma vie,
à mes choix de carrière.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Nathalie a une espèce
d'énergie frondeuse, fonceuse.
annonce son cabinet fantôme.
La député de Terrebonne sera
critique des comptes publics
liés à la pandémie.YVYVYVYVYVYÇT
chef, Bloc québécois
d'une longue carrière politique,
je lui ai dit, et je le pense,
de ministre des Finances.
ocococococococococococococ,
par contre.
- Comment vous accueillez
Mme Sinclair-Desgagné?
- Avec tout le poids
des responsabilités que...
effectivement que je...
je pousse le gouvernement
à être le plus transparent
- La députée est ravie deoioioie
au service des Canadiens,
dans un Québec souverain.ididide
qu'un jour, je n'aurai plus
un pays. Donc, un jour,
cett
je ne la gravirai plus;
ça va